10,000 years ago the average human life
lasted just over 30 years and then a
hundred years ago that number was up to
50 and if you were born in the last few
decades in the developed world then your
life expectancy is 80 years but that is
of course assuming that no major
breakthroughs happen during your
lifetime that can slow the process of
Aging and that may be a very bad
assumption there's a new series on
National Geographic Channel which was
developed with GE and the show's
creators wanted to present my take on
Aging so I'm here at the GE Global
Research Center to talk to principal
scientist dr. Fiona Ginty and this would
be kind of an example of you know one of
the types of images we would generate so
what are we looking at here so these are
our cells that are are actively dividing
and these are sounds that are heading on
their way to death or apoptosis aging is
not recognized as a disease I mean there
are plenty of diseases we do acknowledge
like diabetes heart disease Alzheimer's
and at their core aging may be
responsible for all of them and yet
aging seems natural because it's
something that we do from birth and for
a while it makes us better bigger
stronger faster more intelligent but
then at some point in your life it
reverses and aging makes our bodies
decay in degrade why is that why do we
have to age why do our bodies have to
decay well scientists are now realizing
there is a fundamental cellular
mechanism at the heart of aging do we
age at the macroscopic level because our
cells are aging at the microscopic level
to a great extent yes there's only a
finite number of times a cell will
divide key discovery was made by a
biologist named hayflick he was studying
normal human cells and what he found was
they can only divide a finite number of
times on average it's about 50 beyond
that the cell becomes
senescent which means it's a aged cell
it can divide no longer it lives for a
little while but it's the accumulation
of these senescence cells in our bodies
that leads to aging on the macroscopic
scale so it's as though cells have this
little timer inside them that tells them
when to stop dividing but how do they
know and what is that timer so telomeres
are like the so like your shoelaces have
you know a little bit of plastic at the
ends to stop them from fraying
so telomeres are like the ends of your
shoelaces but for chromosome but for
chromosomes so they stopped the chromis
they keep the chromosome together and
they stop it sticking to other
chromosomes so every time a cell divides
and it loses some of the telomere they
estimate about 200 base pairs why is
that why can't it just coffee to the end
you know it's just sort of really the
mechanics of it you know there's only so
much space when they DNA polymerase does
its job or its core application yet so
the telomere and the telomere getting
shorter is like your molecular clock the
cellular clock inside each cell that
tells it how many times it has divided
would you want to have your telomeres
measured at well people do get their
telomeres measured there have been
associations made with lifestyle with
exercise showing that longer telomeres
are associated with a more active
lifestyle exercise what if there was a
way to stop the telomeres from
shortening if we could do that maybe the
cells would live forever there's another
enzyme involved called telomerase and it
keeps rebuilding like it doesn't let the
telomere ever shrink so it rebuilds the
telomere right exactly there is one
animal that doesn't seem to age and that
is the lobster it just gets bigger over
time it doesn't get weaker and it's
chromosomes don't change it has long
telomeres that do not shorten so it only
dies when it gets eaten by something
else
like us
so how could we be more like a lobster
some people would say maybe I want my
telomerase to be higher for longer
mm-hmm would that help
I mean would that keep us younger I mean
it's balanced because you know in cancer
you've got perfect example of telomerase
being active and it becomes an
unregulated growth situation this is the
double-edged sword of telomeres and
telomerase cancer cells have really long
telomeres and they can divide
indefinitely and that is the problem
with cancer cancer is dividing cells
that won't stop and they won't die so in
a way cancer is the immortal cell living
within us so maybe we've developed the
aging process maybe we have telomeres
that shorten for a very good reason
because otherwise they could become
cancerous
so one of the theories there is that the
cells divide that limited number of
times because they it stops them from
accumulating damage that may be
detrimental so there is some cause them
to become cancer exactly over the past
hundred years developments in medicine
have increased human lifespan more than
we could have imagined and I can only
expect that the next 100 years will
bring
similarly incredible results I'm not
sure where or how they will take place
but you can bet that your life
expectancy today will not be the actual
age at which you die you want to find
out more about the future of aging well
then you should definitely check out the
episode of breakthrough which was
directed by Ron Howard that's airing on
Sunday November 29th at 9:00 8:00
central that is just one of six episodes
of breakthrough which was developed by
National Geographic Channel and GE so I
want to thank them for supporting
veritasium and I want to thank you for
watching oh and I also made a video
about the future of energy it's over on
the GE YouTube channel so go check it
out